our next speaker is Rasmus who was a
postdoctoral scholar at Harvard and he
will be telling us about matrix
marketing nails and their applications
randomized linear algebra yeah thanks
for the introduction Joel and thank you
to the organizers for inviting me and I
guess I should plug this in yeah so my
hope is to look at a particular example
of using matrix martingales in numerical
linear algebra coming up and try to
convince you that you know you should
probably do that too it seems to be a
really good tool okay so let's start
with just concentration of scalar random
variables not matrices
we've got random X that's the sum of
little X I random variables that are
each real value they're independent and
let's say they have mean zero and then
we ask is this approximately zero with
high probability
right so Bernstein's inequality will
give us some concrete conditions under
which this is true so this is that okay
if it's also always true that our random
variable is absolutely bounded so
absolute value bounded by R and the
variance of all these values all these
little random variables sum together is
that most Sigma squared then we get a
probability that a bound saying that the
the sum of these guys X is probably not
larger than epsilon in absolute value
with some good probability for a large
enough Epsilon
so for example I just picked some
parameter values if epsilon is 1/2 and R
and Sigma squared are both like 1 over
log tau we'll get a probability bound of
town it's not important that you parse
that right now it's just to give you a
big sense of you know you choose some
parameters you get some problem ok now I
said I was gonna talk about martingales
I'll talk about matrix martingales
particularly but first let's just
remember what's a martingale maybe it's
been a while since you used one so we've
got a random X this is the set up from
before the important things were it was
the summer things the things were
independent and they had 0 me this is
not a very flexible set of conditions
like if I'm doing algorithms usually my
things are quickly not independent ok so
meeting matrix mine Gail sorry give you
a situation where you can deal with
proving concentration even when things
are not independent you need the second
condition to be changed so you ask for
something a bit stronger here namely
that not only are your individual
variables 0 mean would you put some
order on them from X 1 through X ok and
you say that X I is mean 0 conditional
on any set of outcomes for the previous
variables so it still means 0 no matter
what happened before so I'm gonna write
that summarize it as X I conditional on
the previous steps this means it ok
so let's remember Bernstein's inequality
and see if we can get the same kind of
thing for Martine deals
you can that it's them called Friedman's
inequality this is at least one way to
get it a martingale concentration bound
so again we switch from independence to
asking for a zero mean condition now we
want to prove a probability bound like
this okay so I think many of us in the
audience here have used problems down so
it just yet another one but you probably
haven't seen this one so we'll be a
little bit careful about understanding
it it gets a little bit more complicated
in the conditions now because we don't
get to just say that the variance
measured by summing up the individual X
I and squaring them is small we get a
different variance object that we need
to control so we want to say that the
sum over X I squared conditional on
previous steps this sum is small okay
this is harder to do because this is now
a random variable this variance object
for X I that depends on what the
previous outcomes were it's not
independent from it and we need to bound
the sum anyway okay but that's maybe
that's a lot to ask for
so Friedman gives us a little bit of
extra flexibility it says you don't
always need to bound this you just need
to bound it with a good probability okay
so if it's usually the case that the
variance object the in the natural
definition for martingales which was
this thing if it's usually the case that
this thing is small you'll get a
probability
okay so you get a different random
variable that acts like a variance and
you have to say this is usually
well-behaved and then things will go
through so if this has a low probability
of being a greater than some threshold
Sigma squared my like my variance they
now get the Bernstein probability bound
except for a little fudge of an extra
Delta probability okay
so this is what martingales do for you
they say you can basically pretend that
you're doing Bernstein if you can
control this funny variance
okay so that was Friedman's inequality
but to make it exciting we need matrices
so there's a matrix Bernstein inequality
which is just it's due to trop sitting
right here Joel and Oliveira sorry yes
there are different versions so this is
just Bernstein the the concentration
inequality that we saw but sort of
adapted to a matrix case so now you are
random variable X is a D PI D symmetric
matrix in this setting that I'm
considering sum over X I so it's a sum
of little x i's that are also d by d
symmetric matrices the x i are
independent they're mean 0 their
spectral norm is always small and this
variance object here has small spectral
norm also and then we get with like the
same symbols down here exactly the same
kind of probability statement saying
that the thing is probably concentrated
like it's unlikely that the sum has
spectral norm greater than zero there's
some important changes we got a D here
which is the dimension of the matrices
so the probabilities get a bit worse
this is basically because we need to
Union bound over D different eigen
values that can go wrong something like
that the other thing that you should be
careful with is that this is a funny way
of measuring variance okay each x I
squared is a matrix we're taking
expectations of some funny matrices
we're adding them all up together and
then we're taking a norm this is going
to be extremely important that we have a
funny notion of variance for
applications
so can we get a matrix Freedman the
answers yes and we're just making all
the same changes as we did in the scalar
case so we get zero mean conditional on
previous steps we get this variance
conditional on previous steps has to
usually be small
here are some parameter examples the
only thing that changed from doing
scalar Bernstein way back in the day
when we started on an earlier slide is
that you need a D in this lock to get
rid of this guy if you want small
probabilities okay so what's the
takeaway it's that you can do
concentration on martingales but you
have to worry about some extra object
and for us it's this funny notion of
variance which is called the predictable
quadratic variation and which is a
random variable so we're gonna be a
little have to be a little bit careful
for thinking about it I I think you can
come up with other random objects to
control instead of this one and that
could give you a maybe a turn-off like
version of this too okay now we want to
think about an application so we're
going to talk about laplacian matrices
which are maybe not familiar to everyone
here so we'll just do a quick definition
so the plastic matrices are matrices
that we use to talk about graphs
undirected graphs so we have graph G
with vertices V and edges eat some
positive edge weights let's say that
there are n vertices and M edges here
I've got a graph on three vertices I'm
gonna build the laplacian of this graph
so it's a matrix that I associated with
an undirected graph to help me talk
about the graph
okay so I'm gonna build it it's gonna be
an M by n matrix same so a column and a
row for each vertex and I'm gonna build
it by summing together little baby
Laplace Ian's one for each edge so now I
just need to tell you how to make the
baby laplacian of an edge so let's look
at the edge between a and B and build a
baby laplacian for it so again it's
still an N by n matrix
it only has entries in the rows and
columns for a and B and it's just a 1 on
the diagonal and a minus 1 on the a B
off the animals and then we scale it by
whatever is the weight of the edge in
the graph which is a positive number
then we add them together we get the
plane of the graph I have more
definitions but I don't have time for
them so there are many equivalent
perspectives on the laplacian but we'll
just keep with this one so let's build
an example it's a graph on three
vertices there's an edge of weight one
between vertex one and vertex two it
puts out one on the diagonal for one and
two and a minus one on the one two off
diagonals okay an edge great way to
between vertex 1 and vertex 3 it puts a
2 on the diagonal for a 1 and 3 and a
minus 2 on the 1/3 off by another edge
between vertex 2 and vertex 3 and adding
them all together gives us the laplacian
of the graph okay so theoretical
computer scientists we just love solving
the plasti linear equations because it
lets us do a lot of fun algorithms so
there's a very basic building block so
it was got very excited people got very
excited when Spielman and tang in 2004
showed that you can solve these linear
equations in time that's nearly linear
in the number of nonzero entries of the
matrix which is just the number of edges
in the graph so this is a very useful
tool but let's not talk about why we
just want to learn about martingales to
me then there was a lot of other work
making this much much more reasonable
and I'm just gonna focus on one
particular paper which gives a very
simple algorithm first
these linear equations and it uses
matrix models okay so we want to solve a
laplacian linear equation so we've got L
and B and we want to find X such that L
X equals B okay the classical way to do
this is Gaussian elimination which says
let's find an upper triangular matrix u
such that u transpose u equals L and
then we'll set X equal to u inverse u
transpose inverse times B okay but the
last step is easy because we can solve
linear equations in upper and lower
triangular matrices very
straightforwardly okay first you look at
the row that only has one entry you
solve in that row then you look at the
row where that only has two entries but
you know the answer for one of them you
solve for that row and so on okay if you
didn't follow that you can think about
it offline but it's not a terribly hard
exercise but how do we get the U
transpose u well we'll talk about that
in a second first let's see what's our
algorithm going to be it's it's Gaussian
elimination is not fast in general it's
an N cubed time algorithm but we'll make
it fast
by doing approximate Gaussian
elimination so we're going to find a you
that's upper triangular such that u
transpose U is approximately equal to
the matrix L so this is weaker than what
we had before so what are we winning
well we'll gain that you will be sparse
and we'll be able to compute it very
quickly and then the fact that it's only
approximately a decomposition of the
matrix we want it is not going to be
much of an issue we'll do log 1 over
epsilon iterations of solving linear
equations in the wrong matrix fixing the
left over error and then we when we've
repeated this a few times we get an
epsilon approximate solution in some
motion of approximate that I haven't
told you about yet but we'll get there
so it's not a big problem that it's only
approximate
okay so Sushant Satya and I showed that
when L is a laplacian matrix with M
non-zeros you can find an M log cubed
and time an upper triangular matrix with
M log cubed and non-zeros that's a
pretty good approximation in the sense
that it gives a decomposition that's
approximately equal to our starting
matrix in a way that's sufficient for
solving linear equations questions about
that statement it's a constant factor
approximation and spectral noise it's a
very very strong statement okay
so let's remember how Gaussian
elimination works there's a slightly
unusual perspective going on here but if
you don't see you know there if you
don't remember the difference it's not
important but we take an additive
perspective on it so let's take a matrix
M that's PSD and let's do Gaussian
elimination to it here's an example okay
so first we find the rank one matrix
that agrees with M on the first row and
call so that's the first role in com
here's the rank one matrix that agrees
with it let's subtract the rank one
matrix now it's zero in the first one
column what's left and we say we have
eliminated the first variable what's
left is a PSD matrix and we can repeat
so we're going to find a rank one matrix
that agrees with our matrix on the next
row and column here it is and we can
subtract it there's zero in the first
and second row and column we've
eliminated the secondary and we can keep
repeating this until we've written all
parts of the matrix as Rank 1 terms and
notice a very special structure the
second term has nonzero entries only
from the second entry onwards the third
term has nonzero entries only from the
third entry onwards and so on so we can
rearrange this as the product of the
lower triangular matrix and an upper
triangular matrix this is just this
column goes with this column is my first
rank one term this
goes sorry for this row this column goes
with this row is my second rank one term
and so on now if we transpose that lower
triangular matrix we see that we found
our u transpose u so that was Gaussian
elimination now what's special about
doing Gaussian elimination on Laplace
it's the remaining matrix after we pull
out some rank one parts is another
laplacian okay so let's see an example
of this here we have a laplacian matrix
a i'm going to write it as a rank one
term that agrees with the first row and
column and then what's left see here's
the rank one term you can see that it's
rank one because i now write it as an
outer product of the vector with itself
and then look at what's left
it's another laplacian you're not used
yet to check in quickly whether
something is a laplacian so maybe you
know don't try but it is another passing
okay so we saw something special about
laplacian so we saw gaussian elimination
let's talk about why it's slow so
solving alex equals beat by Gaussian
elimination can take order n cube time
even when the matrix is the laplacian
and even when the input matrix is sparse
okay and the main issue is what's called
fill so we've got a apply C&L and we
want to eliminate a row and convey which
in the graph we can think about the
corresponding graph it's a vertex V and
there's a bunch of you know it has
nonzero entries this corresponds to
edges to other vertices in the graph so
let's look at the graph picture for what
Gaussian elimination does so it says you
know this variable would disappear and
its edges to other vertices will
disappear but then in the remaining
matrix when we look at that as a graph
we no longer have this vertex but we
have a clique on its neighbors so this
is what Gaussian elimination does when
we pull out this rank one term we're
going to create a clique on the
neighbors so the nation plates a clique
on the neighbors of B
okay these clicks can very quickly make
the graph grow dense and this is what
makes Gaussian elimination slow so this
happens for example in an expander graph
that doesn't work at all
there's no ordering for an expander
graph it always gives in cute okay and
that's not just expanders that's not
that hard to construct okay so but
there's hope
because Laplace Ian's are particularly
susceptible to sketchy right I would say
sparse vacation but we're in a room
where you say sketching it's a
particular kind of sketching right so we
can specify this click OK and we can
hope that the new matrix is a good
approximation of the old right but we're
going to have to do this a lot of times
right I probably can't apply a matrix
Chernoff bound every single time I
eliminate a variable I would go wrong
but this is exactly what we're going to
do we're going to eliminate variables
and just immediately without even in
fact we don't have to write down the
clique ever we can sample from it
without writing it down and this is
going to be our algorithm for doing
approximate Gaussian elimination now we
won't have time to go into the same
playing exactly but it's three lines
it's very straightforward three lines of
code so Gaussian elimination said pick a
vertex be to eliminate add the clique
created by eliminating V and repeat
until you're done approximate Gaussian
elimination says pick a random vertex V
to eliminate sample the clique created
by eliminating V and repeat until you're
done and that's the whole
so is this something done again by
effective resistance like no but you
don't need to calculate anything yeah
and for the numerical analysis people in
the audience of whom there are many this
very much resembles doing randomized
incomplete Chomsky factorization so in a
way you can think of this is us saying
well the algorithm actually works and we
can prove it on any laplacian matrix but
we have to randomize it and neither of
these randomizations is an artifact so
picking a random vertex is not the only
way to do well I think but there are
orderings that will give you trouble and
random orderings work ok so remember the
goal was to get that you know that u
transpose u in the end is going to be
approximately equal to L so how are we
going to prove it we're going to show
that in expectation u transpose u is
indeed equal to L and then we're going
to show that it's concentrated around
its expectation and then we'll apply a
concentration bound it will be matrix
Freedman to show that it's approximately
equal to L with high probability in in a
useful spectral sense so first let's
look at the expectation so consider
eliminating the first variable and now
I'm going to call the original laplacian
l0 and then I write it as a Rank 1 term
I'm not doing any sampling yet a Rank 1
term that's the row and column I pulled
out and then a remaining graph plus a
clique created by elimination right now
I sample the clique all right this gives
me my approximate matrix after one
elimination let's think and let's call
del one let's think about the
expectation of L 1 ok well the
expectation of well 1 we're not sampling
the rank 1 term so we don't need to
worry about that we're not sampling the
remaining graph so we don't need to
worry about that we can push the
expectation past all those and just say
well suppose that we get the clique
right an expectation then the whole
thing adds up
to the original matrix okay and then the
expectation of l1 is l0 so let L IP our
approximation after I eliminations okay
if we insure at every step that the
specified cliquing expectation is orig
is equal to the clique that Gaussian
elimination would create then we'll get
that the expectation of Li is Li minus
one okay and now with the way that I've
defined martingales this says that the
expectation of the difference is zero
and this will be true conditional on the
previous steps right it just has to be
true locally that we're preserving the
expectation of the clique and we got a
martingale and I think also that I like
you to maybe consider whether this
shouldn't be a fairly generic phenomenon
right what I'm saying is that algorithms
like to be locally sensible right and
locally sensible is like preserving the
expectation is in this particular step
right and that's exactly what gives you
a martingale property so martingales are
a very natural fit I think for
algorithmic analysis provided that you
can find the right operator where some
expectation stays the same although if
you go read about Dube martingales
maybe you don't even really need to keep
the expectation right although of course
you'll need some control over the
expectation okay so we're running you
know slowly out of time but you know
let's talk about the approximation a
little bit is it this one right is that
is that what I'm going for
no no if I had this kind of spectral
approximation it wouldn't help me solve
linear equations at all like for linear
equations small eigenvalues are
important because when I invert the
matrix they blow up to be large
eigenvalues and this spectral norm is
just telling me that I got some large
eigenvalues right
so we need something completely
different we need to measure the
spectrum in a kind of relative sense
which we do by dividing everything
through by L before we do approximations
okay but for matrices dividing through
by L means multiplying by L minus half
on each side so we transform our
approximate decomposition apply L minus
half on each side it's just for analysis
of course now L becomes identity and so
we want this thing to be close to
identity and that's enough for solving
linear equations okay it's hard work to
keep writing L minus half everywhere so
let's give it a name and call it it's a
tropic position I'll put things in
isotropic position by calling them blue
and putting a bar on them just you know
for those of you who might have trouble
seeing the blue the goal is now to make
u transpose U and isotropic position be
approximately equal to L okay that's the
most important thing together with the
PSD order or the lova order which I'll
just remind you says that if I have two
symmetric matrices a is less than B it's
a partial order on matrices if for all X
X transpose ax is less than X transpose
BX okay let's have some random variables
okay so we're just sampling edges the
random variables look like either you
scale up the edge by something to
counter the fact that you only keep it
by probability P or you set it to zero
okay and this clearly has expectation L
e okay it's not exactly what's happening
in the algorithm but let's just think
about flipping a coin for every edge the
real analysis is not much different then
we have some zero mean variables just
subtract the meat and then we call them
blue to put them in isotropic position
and now we remember the predictable
quadratic variation right this is the
hard thing to control some funny object
like this in order to apply martingale
concentrate
so we wanted to show that this thing is
usually well behaved
okay now we can get a promise it turns
out if we do our sampling sensibly and
this is subtle but let's not worry about
it right now and it's often not the
hardest part that every sample that we
make has low variance okay and now I
think we're almost at the message the
last message I want to get across which
is that the variance was a matrix right
and I told you it was a funny notion of
variance
it looks like the laplacian of the edge
in isotropic position okay that's a time
bomb because this seems simple but it
turns out that we're very close to
something very powerful now it's somehow
relating the variance of each sample
back to the structure of the graph is a
very powerful statement but it's not
enough because we're constantly changing
the structure of the graph and that's I
think one of the hard things that you
know we need to get used to form our
tamils
so remember that when we're doing
elimination we eliminate a vertex we
create a clique on its neighbors right
then we sample the clique and I just
told you that the variance that we
create looks like little baby Laplace
Ian's on these edges but an isotropic
position which was this weird
normalization now it turns out that in
the lava order this matrix is less than
the one the edges so just the variance
created here these baby laplacian are
less than the corresponding edges of the
vertex that we eliminated and this is
actually not hard to see because you get
this matrix by pulling out a PSD rank
one term from this matrix okay but now I
solved the problem of the fact that
we're changing the structure of the
graph because we went from having
variance in the new structure to getting
variance in the old structure
now comes the other important part I
picked random vertices but it's easy to
think about what does a random vertex
and then getting bearings here look like
because I'm getting variants of edges of
a vertex equal to edges of a vertex but
when I sum that over random vertices I
just get the whole graph because I can
pick either end of an edge right there
are two ways that I can get the edge
pick one and pick the other and I'm
averaging over all these different ways
of getting the edges so I get each edge
twice and I divide through by the number
of vertices okay so the whole variance
adds up to the whole previous graph in
isotropic position divided by the number
of vertices there are some fudging
constant but in isotropic position the
laplacian is just identity so the trick
is that we can really understand what
the predictable quadratic variation is
doing so we can control the variance
okay and now we just sum up the variance
let's skip this we sum up the van's over
different rounds and we're dividing by
number of vertices in each round and
getting a small matrix otherwise the
first elimination we have n vertices so
we're dividing by n the second we have n
minus 1 vertices and so on so this one
over number vertices just gives us a
login because it adds up to a harmonic
sum well right there's not a lot of
variance it's the whole story so the
whole thing works
now summary martingales are a natural
fit for algorithmic analysis
understanding the predictable quadratic
variation or some other similar object
may be is key and I really think you
should be able to find other cases of
this we have some cases so there was an
unlined row sampling by Cohen Moscow and
pecho key we have this approximate
Gaussian elimination that I talked about
today we've also been using it for semi
streaming graph sparse efficient for
solving directed Laplace ian's for
proving
tration bounds for a negatively
dependent matrix random variables so you
know go home and take out your
martingale s and do stuff with them
thank you questions so bad elimination
ordering is like suppose even this is a
bit silly but suppose the graph is just
a ring or like the global structure
looks like a ring then eliminating in
order around the ring is a bad idea
because you're sort of going to be
accumulating variance in a in a bad way
yeah
so we have some cases of this but not a
whole lot so we can generalize it to
something called connection Laplace
Ian's
we can also generalize it to directed
laplacian which basically give you ways
of like basically finding any
information about a random walk in a
directed graph in nearly linear time so
I think that's a very cool primitive but
whether you can do it for you know
everything we don't know and maybe don't
think so but that's a very big question
yeah so all the other cases that I
mentioned connection laplacian and
directed laplacian also have this
property that they're class that are
closed under Gaussian elimination so you
do some Gaussian elimination you get
back another one of that class if you
find another class like that you can
probably do the same thing I mean it's
also true for positive definite matrices
but something else then goes wrong so
and the fact that these matrices you
know always have a decomposition into
small parts
more questions
all right lunch time let's think
[Applause]